every guy six foot three every guy earns  this amount of money every guy looks  like this etc etc and that filters down  to other things because then they also  think those kind of guys usually have a  lot of options therefore they might mess  about a little bit they might cheat  whatever so now they think oh guys cheat  well not really you're ignoring 80 of  the guys because you're only dealing  with the top 20. so they have a very  skewed view of what guys are there's  guys like we said earlier ugly guys  ugly guys won't matter  like if they're if they substance like  supplement it with other things money  look status etc etc etc right so if but  there's a big big proportion of guys who  aren't doing that and those kind of guys  are completely invisible to girls